[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis fier d'être démocrate je vais
gouverner comme un président américain
je travaillais aussi dur pour ceux qui
ont voté pour moi que pour ceux qui
n'ont pas voté pour moi
avec la même force il a mis fin à une
mandature celle de rome qui avait
beaucoup heurté qui avaient beaucoup
séparait pas simplement les américains
mais aussi les européens avec les états
unis
en élisant joe biden de mettre fin à une
présidence trump brutale brouillonne
qu'il était très anxiogène pour le monde
de la halle trump avait choisi de
quitter les accords de paris sur le
réchauffement climatique félicité aussi
kamala harris qui sera la première femme
vice-présidente aux états unis ce qui
est pour moi un signal majeur envoyé à
toutes les femmes à toutes les filles
vous important que l'élection de jeunes
enfants je pense que c'est un signal
aussi important qu'il faut saluer vous
souhaitez qu'une femme présidente en
ce que je souhaite certainement pas
n'importe quelle femme présidente parce
qu'elle est une femme
excusez moi monsieur sport touche de
vous dire que l'élection de marine le
pen est certainement pour moi un moteur
dans mon engagement politique
un moteur pour s'opposer au populisme
peut-être que je suis la première femme
dans ce bio vins mais je ne serai pas la
dernière
parce que chaque petite fille qui
regardent ce soir qui voit que c'est un
pays où tout est possible tout est
possible quelquefois le pire on l'a vu
avec donald rome le risque pour la
démocratie était sérieux il reste
sérieux alors qu'ils contestent même
l'élection
nous avons vu ce qu'une présidence
américaine pouvait avoir comme
conséquence sur un certain nombre de
sujets ces images avec le message byden
fleurissent sur la toile
comprenez au revoir alors jeu de mots
est évident avec le nom du nouveau
président des états unis fait l'ambiance
qui contraste avec cette image c'est
donald trump qui joue au golf au même
moment scène presque surréaliste
alors qu'il vient d'apprendre la
victoire de son adversaire il est
photographié avec une jeune mariée
quelques instants plus tard sur twitter
il se pose en vainqueur 71 millions de
votre légaux c'est le meilleur score
jamais obtenu par un président sortant
ça sera probablement en tout cas on le
souhaite le retour à une approche
coopérative sur un certain nombre de
sujets multilatéraux et je pense
évidemment aux questions de santé
l'enjeu planétaire en ce moment c'est la
gestion de la pandémie
oui je suis prêt et je propose ma
candidature mais il ya un mais je
demande une investiture populaire
par conséquent je saurai candidats
définitivement si et seulement si j'ai
recueilli 150 mille signatures de
parrainage
on sent un frémissement je dirais
épidémique avec une hausse qui pourrait
être de 20 % du nombre de cas la semaine
précédant la semaine dernière contre des
hausses qui était plus important
qu'avant mais ça n'a pas suffi à enrayer
l'épidémie ce qui montre que le
confinement qui est annoncé par le
présent la république et qui est en
vigueur dans notre pays était plus que
jamais nécessaire
mon intention est que le cent cinquante
mille personnes puissent avoir le
pouvoir d' investir un candidat
aujourd'hui vous savez que seuls 500
élus veulent le faire c'est pourquoi
je commence à populariser et entretenir
cette idée que non seulement les
citoyens peuvent désigner leur chef de
l'état mais en plus ils peuvent
l'investir c'est surtout ça qui est le
plus important